india's second wave just keeps on
getting worse
oxygen still in short supply
[Music]
the hospitals around the country are
overwhelmed
the numbers of dead are rising and now
they've run out of vaccines
they queued in their hundreds to try to
get inoculated
this was ghaziabad in uttar
many states simply said they just didn't
have enough
and suspended the program
this was a rare sight in the indian
capital a vaccination center
with some stock to the relief of those
who had booked
you feeling excited tell me how why
because like we've already me and my
family have already had covered
so now i think this will be a good thing
so that we don't get infected again
this was meant to be the big roll out
vaccinations for all
18 years and older but like so much to
do with india's coronavirus crisis
the government seems to have got it
wrong and didn't appreciate its huge
domestic demand
fewer than two percent of india's
population have been fully inoculated
whilst nearly 70 million doses have been
sent overseas since january
that would easily have been enough to
inoculate the whole of delhi
mumbai and calcutta and it's not just
vaccines the country's short of
it's all medicines used to treat the
virus
do you have any rem disorder for
coronavirus
do you have any of the medicine have you
got
rem disavow nautilus not available
because they're out of stock because of
outdoor stuff because of
low production because of their more
many more
circumstances the indian prime minister
was praying at a sikh temple
days after his government had ordered
the mass vaccination
as well as reassured the nation that the
acute shortage of
oxygen was being sorted
but a few miles away from the temple we
saw evidence to the country
the queues are getting longer the
backlog's getting bigger
and the crisis shows no sign of letting
up
delhi high court judges have now stepped
in ordering the government to ensure the
capital gets adequate
oxygen as yet more hospitals said they'd
run out
and patients had died when the cases
started rising up i thought government
had a plan
but turns out they didn't within the
first week i understood that the
governments have no idea
they're not prepared for anything we
don't have enough ventilators in one
hospital forget about all the
whatever we need for the entire city or
the entire nation
india is very much in the eye of the
covered tornado
and little is happening to stop it
rampaging through the country
at a dizzying speed alex crawford sky
news
delhi